grab the super chat real quick here
stone cold hey there love your content
thanks brother appreciate that
let's move on to the next one the bad
choice is crowd
people that make bad choices man
what is that law do i have the 48 laws
of power book here i think it's law
number 10.
robert greene's book this is
this is a go-to book for every guy every
year
i believe law number 10 is the unhappy
and the unlucky
am i right yes
avoid the unhappy and the unlucky here
i'll just read this to you
you can die from somebody else's misery
emotional states
are as infectious as diseases you may
feel you are helping
a drowning man but you are only
participating in your own disaster
the unfortunate sometimes draw a
misfortune on themselves
they will also draw it on you associate
with the happy
and fortunate instead
can i come back to the microphone
can i be any more clearer than that
people that
make a series of bad choices in their
life
will start inviting these bad choices
into your life
i've noticed a pattern and if they have
back to back to back failures
and this happens a lot in certain
demographics which i'm not gonna
spend too much time highlighting but you
guys know what i'll talk about if you're
a regular viewer but people that make
these bad choices back to back to back
they don't even see them as bad choices
they see them as
i was unlucky
you're just unlucky that's it you got
you got knocked up and have four
different kids from four different
fathers and you're just unlucky
unlucky in in what exactly
did you take any ownership in those
choices that you made
right you know the guy that burns
through
half a million dollars trying to get a
startup off the ground
it has nothing to show for it or the guy
that's
been in business for 12 years running
conferences and doesn't have a pot to
piss in or a window to throw it out of
they got nothing to show for it
you made some bad choices it's incumbent
upon you as a guy
to focus on your landscape again you
have your perimeter your inner circle
and your outer circle
it's incumbent upon you to make a
decision on who you're going to let on
the inside
you should never let anybody on the
inside that's
makes bad choices you certainly should
not invite a woman into your life that
makes bad choices especially if you're
going to invite her in your house and do
something
matt butcher says please tell me back
chicks
are on the list i've recently split with
one
and she sent me crazy what's a back
check i've never heard of a back check
before
are you talking about women coming back
into your life that you've broken up
with
yeah i mean you break up somebody you
should not allow them back in what is
that
iron rule number seven or something like
that once you take the garbage to the
curb you leave it there
you go back out your neighbors see your
rifling through the garbage they don't
want to see that
super sticker from stone cold thanks
brother
all right so number four was people that
make bad choices
also law number 10 and the 48 laws of
power do not invite the unhappy and the
unlucky
into your life they are toxic they will
bring they will make their problems your
problems
do not let other people make their
your problems smarten up guys
you